oh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
hey babe hi let me tell you something
let me tell you something right now
July 4th July 3rd what is that July
um July 3rd uh um Seinfeld's bit on it
when cows tell you the expiration date
when you're milking them that's right
okay go ahead okay I like Seinfeld shout
out Jerry we know you're listening
um July 4th July 4th which by the way
Independence Independence Day everybody
thought July 2nd founding father son was
going to be July 2nd 1776. that's when
actually the real [__] went down okay
then it only happened on July 4th I
think because like a couple of the
delegates you know they're traveling
horse and buggy so four is taking credit
for two four Benjamin Franklin said July
2nd 1776 will go down in infamy with all
Colonial Americans it was like
okay you're wrong okay it's July 4th but
I know that it was last week but July
4th I went to the great trans
commentary's house I called Jasmine Now
jazz commentary and it makes me laugh
challenge Jasmine yeah Jasmine I told
Jazz for Halloween I want her to dress
up as Sunny for A Bronx Tale As Jazz
momentary that's what I want
um so I call it Jazz palmitary and I
mean I laugh hard and she's not amused
but it's whatever can I ask you a
question I don't mean to interrupt you
you're gonna get back to it we're
talking about July but right here right
now
if something happened like in a Sci-Fi
movie sci-fi comedy or whatever whatever
or just scenes in the future I don't
know the circumstances take them as as
facts where Jasmine's head
has to be attached to Chazz palmintery's
Body medically fine right she has
Jasmine's memories thoughts brain
personality speech her head is Jasmine
her body 100 is jazz voluntaries right
penis balls everything
but that's the only way she was able to
live there was something happened and
the doctors came in and they were in car
accident together with Chaz is gone and
she couldn't and something happened and
they said we she is a hundred percent
saved she's she's gonna have the same
life her brain is the same age would you
what would happen to your relationship
with you and Jasmine if just right
around the neck it blended into Chad's
neck and then she had chaz's body would
you be able to obviously you're not gay
and so you probably wouldn't be
interested in being physical with the on
the neck down would you still be able to
be with her and doctor and live with her
and kiss her and everything
and and and you know and she's in chaz's
body
yeah like so I think that what would
happen there I think what would happen
is most likely is most likely our
relationship would remain the same as it
is now okay barely acknowledging each
other
I'm just dealing with the goddamn kids
see like it wouldn't really be a thing
yeah it wouldn't really be a thing I
would say it might actually improve
things because now I'm with my
girlfriend and my close friend okay now
that now I've Blended two people that I
really love and enjoy the company of
together now it's great okay and
um where she was chazz's does she has to
be chazz's height then you know he's
like six six isn't he said it would be
like what would be even crazier is if
chaz's head was on Jasmine's body yeah
yeah it would be to just what channels
with a big fat ass yeah would you be
able to have sex with Chaz like with
Jasmine palm and Terry yeah
who would you be able to
be intimate with more
Jazz
she has his head on Jasmine's body where
Jasmine's head on chassis I think I'd be
more intimate with
Jazz's head on Jasmine's body wait who
Chad
but you have to look at that face you
know what I mean I think that would you
be able to be intimate with
chasmine
well I had to kiss Chas palmettiere on
the lips from my CBS pilot so I've
already done it okay so I can deal with
that okay
I think that I would actually get to a
point where I had limited problems
with chaz's head on John
's position
and like think of Chaz looking back at
you
laughs
I can't do any of that yeah it's his
brain it's his voice it's just her body
Chrissy babe do it to me babe I but it's
Jasmine's body tattoos everything
everything
I think what happens here
I think I'd have a way
because Jasmine is a beautiful face
that's the thing sure she's beautiful
but so does chats
so the body I don't know that I could
get past the because I don't like a
woman who's taller than me and makes me
feel inferior so I think I would still
have to still don't use the height don't
use the height because that's not
because because look would you be able
to just like hold
chaz's body's hand
and May and hold chaz's body's waist and
kiss Jasmine's head passionately right
while you're holding Jazz like older big
wrinkly manhand right or would you be
able to pick up Jazz's ass while you
kiss himself
which one is more metal oh my God what
you want is more amenable to you
oh my God it's literally one of the
hardest questions I've had in years
what are you doing I think that I
probably would stop man it's tough
so you're basically gonna have to keep
your intimacy to neck up with with with
well they're both chasmine at this point
yes but I can't have sex with the body
which has his body no you'd have to
limit it to that's what I'm saying so I
could have sex with Jasmine's body which
has his face right but also rather do
that look
remember Chaz and all of his sentient
mind is Chad and with Chaz is haircut I
can't change anything about it no but
it's also chives can I have him grow his
hair out
If he if he wants to so I can get he has
a pony to you can get I mean shots with
the ponytail any better that's right
because he still Chas his face but
listen to me listen to me very handsome
man super duper handsome but listen to
me you you when you're having sex this
would be me by the way
if you just put Jasmine's face on that
can you put Jasmine's face on that
picture uh pimpy all right that's please
this is the picture or if you have a
picture like if Jazz posted one of our
socials of her like you know in a
bathing suit or in a like a workout
outfit put chaz's head on that
this way you can look at both of them
let's look at both of them let's get it
let's get one of each so you could
actually look at that okay yeah and say
because look because because here's the
thing I think that'll be hard
sure you could put a bag over chaz's
head and it's Jazz's Body but it's
chaz's Consciousness right so
now you're not gonna fiddle around with
Chaz this is Jasmine post this picture
see this is Jasmine right so now we're
saying this head and hair is on Chazz
palmintery's Body yes or this body with
Jess's face correct
but Chaz is not just chaz's face it's
Chaz
is consciousness so that's what I think
is going to be hard right because you
have your your partner's body there
right but it's it's all the memory and
it's Chaz it's just with her body so
you're gonna have to tell him to be
quiet and maybe put a pillow and then
hope for the best
I'll tell you what though or have Jazz
just like
I think honestly I pick chazz's head on
Jazz's Body because it would be so much
less fights with because Chaz is not
going to argue with me about all this
little minute [__] that Jasmine's
gonna argue with me about because he's
Chas his head Jazzy's face has his face
with a Jasmine
if you tell me it's Jasmine's body Chas
his head but Jasmine's brain yes that's
now that now do that one she has his
head Jasmine's brain and then on J on
chaz's body it's Jasmine's head
but
I have I would have chaz's head turn
around and look at me and go what you
want to eat yes
on
chaz's head would do that yes correct
see that throws like yet another Monkey
Wrench in it because now it's Jasmine's
brain so I'm gonna fight there's gonna
be arguing there's just because she men
and women argue more than men but think
about not even anything personal Jasmine
it's just men and women will argue more
than men and men so but here but listen
to the opposite now right it's it's
Jazz's Body Chas Chaz is
Jasmine's head okay but it's Chaz but
it's Chaz is so how are you doing that
that's the one that I'll take really if
you give me
Jasmine's Consciousness and everything
so it's Chaz it's chaz's Soul
wait but it's chaz's soul and body hold
on hold on
should I call Jasmine right now and ask
her ask her
should we ask her this or should we ask
her give her the scenario wait it says
the food's here Saul has arrived where
but where are you all right I got a
brand new hour of stand-up material I am
filming my hour special in December so
if you want to see it before we put it
out there come see me live August 18th
and 19th Atlantic City The Borgata
September 5th and 6th Irvine California
September 8th Portland 9th Seattle
September 22nd Radio City September 23rd
theater at MSG and then we got Las Vegas
Nevada September 30th and then check
October November December at
chrisdcomedy.com if I'm not coming to
your city let me know about it I'm
coming everywhere especially on the
front row all right guys first things
first the Impractical Jokers and Eric
Andre are hosting a cruise January 22nd
to the 26th in 2024 uh leaving out of
Miami going to the Bahamas it's going to
be insane there's going to be tons of
comics bands DJs chefs everything on
that thing it's like three quarters sold
out you get tickets at get shipfaced
cruise.com uh the last weekend of dates
for the Joker's tour until we start the
second leg next year is happening July
27th 28th and 29th we're going to be at
Nashville at the Grand Ole Opry
Cambridge Field House in Indianapolis
and the stifle theater for two shows in
St Louis that is at
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets
and then your boy is starting these the
last leg of his solo tour getting ready
to film my special in Chicago in in
December so my dates currently are Al
will be at the Albany Funny Bone the
Syracuse Funny Bone uh Bowling Green
Cincinnati Toledo Wilkes-Barre
Pennsylvania Wilmington Delaware Macon
Georgia Savannah Georgia Athens Georgia
Peoria Rockford Cedar Rapids Springfield
all those are going on sale in the
coming week uh at salvolcano comedy.com
pay attention to my socials for the
pre-sale info get good tickets for
everybody else I'll see you guys on the
road
ask her this what are we asking her like
what you think what she thinks you would
do or what she would prefer yes but
she's gonna prefer her Consciousness
probably right because I mean she's
gonna prefer who she is I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say or should we make this
this for her like I said like what if
someone was on like her you know someone
she knew was your head like swap it yeah
so your head is on like her girlfriend's
body yeah like your Consciousness yes
and then her girlfriend's head is on
like your body with her girlfriend's
country like like if my head if like
I'll say yeah like if my head was on
um like who's a good friend like yeah
like her okay got it got it yeah so
should we ask her that or should we ask
her this or is it a twofold I think it's
a twofold I think it's a two let me call
her let me call I think it's a tuple but
I like where he has a theory she should
have the same same type of answer for
both conundrums no right and I'm gonna
send her the pics of what just so she
has him
all right
[Laughter]
hello hey Jazz we got uh we gotta I we I
got a situation here on on you're on hey
babe okay just
just you're on a you're on hey babe okay
now I'm driving okay just listen to me
babe I sent you I sent you text don't
look at them yet or you can when you
come safely to a stoplight but
um okay so so I said to Sal you know
that I call you Jazz commentary and it
really makes me laugh and you've like
had enough of it but I just constantly
call you that so Sal proposed a
mind-blowing question to me that
literally has taken up the first easily
30 minutes of hey babe it might be the
entire episode with this conundrum
what is it okay so
you asked me would you rather what
rather
gone to your head you have to do this
would you rather
Jasmine's head Jasmine's head on Chad's
commentary's body on Jazz pop into
Harry's head
but that has to be
your girlfriend for your life that is
who it is
and and I send you pictures of what each
one look like and so and now keep in
mind keep in mind that it's your it's in
each in each scenario
you like if it was transformative's head
on your body it's your brain and chaz's
head so so but your child's face and
then if it's if it's if it's chaz's
party and your face is chaz's brain so
what do you think AI chose and what do
you think I what do you hope that I
chose
I think AI chose my head on his body and
I think you chose
his head on my body that that is correct
now why where's where's the thought
process so she said she she would choose
her head on Chance's body is what she
wants his butt no but but didn't you
just say that it's chaz's Consciousness
but right what do you think of that
Jazz it's a face swap okay that's fine
I'll say I'll take his body because I
can always change that
you could all interesting so you're
gonna bring modern science into it and
it'll be your head but you'll change
that body but we're saying you can't do
that we're saying no okay Jess no no you
don't know no we need to make one quick
distinction is Jazz's head on chaz's
body Jazz's Consciousness and brain
still so jaz's head is speaking to you
like it always does with chaz's body
that was how he started it but then we
threw in well what if it's Jazz's head
but everything else remains Chaz and so
jazz Jasmine is he her her so Jasmine
still has her Consciousness in her real
body her full physical body but Chaz is
famous jazz so they're two different
things here
so okay let me ask you this so I think
that she would choose her own face and
her own Consciousness on chaz's body
go ahead
you're probably both very attractive
people
and both and you both make really good
sauce
but it's really what you would choose
not cheese okay she needs to be posed
the same question that's the thing okay
so let's all right I'm so I'm thinking
what do you want let me just pause let
me just pose it in a different way so
you can understand what I'm going
through let's say let's say you had only
one option either you ha and this again
this is your partner no listen to me
this is your partner I'm looking at the
pictures
Okay so
so
we by the way we're gonna post this on
our social media when this episode comes
out
right now or for the episode like once
the episode comes out we'll make the
support so you'll Mark that down and
make this is a poll okay gonna come out
um so I mean my head doesn't look bad on
his body it doesn't so so that's what
you like that's okay no no no no no
she's gonna choose her hi sweetie if her
head has her own Consciousness she's
always going to choose her head when she
has his body so make it to conundrum
make it that her consciousness
is in chaz's head that's on her body you
understand Jazz now so that's so so
that's so so you so yeah you like sweat
whatever your hands you look exactly
Jazz you are you everything but your
face and you're everything but your head
your head is chaz's but your brain
inside is still you what you see your
memories
look in the mirror your Chazz
palmintery's face
I can't I can't take that or or would
you think that he would stay with chaz's
full body and Chas his full
Consciousness with your head your face
your face and hair
but it's chaz's body
it's too hard
I know well like
no well give her the question okay so
let me let me uh chazz's face is this is
like freaking me out
so let me put based on my body
okay so let me post and let me pose
what I gotta go where are you going why
don't you tell me what would you prefer
um I I mean at this point I think you're
gonna take trash's Consciousness
Consciousness but I but she needs this
answer for her point of view you guys
are being the perfect couple actually
okay
so let's say
oh my God throw this no but throw the
scenario yes at you yeah so you're let's
say
um why don't we say chaz's wife chaz's
wife Gianna the great Gianna Paul
material who we all know get on this get
on this Photoshop
everybody loves him and Giana
vomitary okay listen to me listen to me
what you have to choose my head my head
and Consciousness on Gianna's body or
Gianna's head on my body what is it what
are you gonna choose it's my body but
it's Gianna's head in Consciousness
that's who you have to be with for the
rest of your life or Giannis or or
announce you with the rest of your life
but I have Gianna's body
Gianna's heading Consciousness on your
body whoa
whoa that means that you would take jazz
is that means the equivalent is you
taking chaz's head in Consciousness on
Jazz's Body so yeah so if she's going to
do it so am I but that's not what you
were doing everybody wow can she explain
her answer yeah explain
okay well one she's an amazing cook
amazing so I would love that in the
house two she's like she's really really
really good with the kids so are you but
I mean she's come on she's Gianna and um
and she's very pretty
so I wouldn't mind looking at her but I
don't want a female body but you don't
want the female body you'd rather have
my body
which before fasting did look female
okay okay
right we didn't get to the Channing
Tatum questions yeah that's that's the
patreon
okay so she's she's basically dating
your body with Gianna's heading on his
head okay so it's not too dissimilar to
one but you're gone you got
yeah so
yeah
oops what happened
now yeah so you guys I don't give a [__]
about me so okay so if it was so then
she her perfect thing would be Gianna's
head on your body with your
Consciousness that would be part but my
Consciousness so you're gonna see
Gianna's face eating boogers yeah
thing here's the thing baby I don't want
to change you at all
well I oh that's not good for them
because that's not good for because
that's not good for the podcast
that's not good for them we're trying to
we have steak you have to see my face
hold on I'm sending you this picture you
have to see
hold on hey what's Chad's doing with
Jazz's guy hey here we go here we go
take a take a look at this one
this is
where are you by the way
that's basically who would date
wait hold on I'm sending I'm sending you
the updated one hold on hold on don't
look at the first one hold on
you
but yeah but then look at you look at
this this is what it would be you Jazz
your head fits seamlessly onto chaz's
body it's so weird
it's legit
you look she looks like Fabio a little
bit she you do she looks do you
literally look like fun with the hair
the hair
really really great how does she look
more like Fabio than you
I don't know idea we both look kind of
look like Fabio so what you would do
let's just get this straight
you would choose
Jasmine's
what other body I personally would
choose Jasmine's body yeah and Chas palm
and Terry's face okay that's I think is
a better consciousness
but but Chaz is consciousness no give
the Consciousness back the Consciousness
where the Consciousness we're not
dealing with anymore because you won't
lose Jazz you'll just lose Jazz's face
right but your memories your memories
her personality is gonna come out of
chaz's face so I'm gonna see chaz's face
on a spin bike yes but it's gonna be
Jasmine but it's gonna be Jasmine but
inside a Jasmine's body but tries his
head so now you're not losing so this is
the deal you're not losing Jasmine but
you're losing her face you're only
keeping her body and her mind you're
losing her face or you don't care about
my face you keep Jasmine's face
completely
right
but it's but it's Jazzy's body
and
challenges Consciousness so I gotta go
with Jasmine's Consciousness Jasmine no
make it Jasmine's consciousness
Jasmine always has a Consciousness her
head is on chaz's body or chaz's head is
on her body which one do you choose
that's it
what we're always questioning your
sexuality anyway so that's true yeah I
know and you know how many times have I
have you and I've been having sex and
I've just been wishing and hoping it
would you I could press a button and
turn you into chats
this is interesting because I feel like
in my own life if this was posed to me I
would want my partner's head because
that's really the connection who they
yeah that's who they are you know I mean
I would hate to have to
not have sex ever again in my life or
work have sex with chess his body you
know what I mean so but but you're gonna
only see chances I do love Jasmine's
face it's her like the best part of her
physically just physically okay no
physically so but then so then that's
it's gonna be her face and her head so
then maybe I'll change it
man's body used to just kind of dealing
with chaz's chaz's penis and balls and
ass yeah I'll just get used to seeing
that in the shower
I cannot picture with long hair at all
all right I gotta go I love you
I gotta go thanks Jess thank you thanks
Jeff chance commentary thank you
bye violet
all right love you bye well regardless
either one chasmine is born Jasmine is
born yeah and it's it that that was and
and that's what I like when we do
episodes like this where you really
challenge me yes I was challenged I it
feels good as a human being to be
challenged that way because it is one of
the hardest things to do is for you to
put me in that situation where switching
heads and bodies it's so hard it's so
hard to really think about it because
again you're sacrificing lust and
connection and love it's all it's it's
it could go A Million Ways let me just
ask you what I could go like two ways
but let me ask you another let me ask
you another thing babe you feel that
Sizzle I feel that Sizzle summer is
heating up you know why
yes the savings with the summer of dash
pass from doordash my God they got the
pass yes yeah and with a dash pass
membership nailed it you can save big
now through July 19th on swimsuits Beach
snacks sunscreen and more everybody
needs sunscreen door Dash is blowing the
doors wide open I like it I love my
doordash I use it all the time uh with
the summer of dash pass you will enjoy
zero dollar delivery fees and reduce
service fees on all eligible orders
making it easier and more affordable
than ever to stock up on all your
favorite summertime Essentials just get
that doordash app you can get deliveries
from restaurants from not even
restaurants anymore from chain
restaurants mom and pop or everything in
between that's all you get access to
thousands of offers ensuring that this
summer is one to remember so kick back
relax let dash pass by door desk door
Dash help you experience the best of
your neighborhood for Less summer of
dash pass is a once a year event you do
not want to miss thanks to the thanks to
the chance to get special access to
members only events whether you're in
sports music or just great snacks get
ready to lower your costs and raise the
bar this summer with limited edition
drops and exclusive items to level up
all season long uh experiencing someone
like Noah the best your best last summer
with a dash pass membership from
doordash today sign up for dash pass now
and you'll get your first month free
plus when you use our promo code get 50
off up to 10 value when you spend 15 or
more on your next dash pass order when
you download the dash the doordash app
and enter the code
[Music]
babe2023 summer that's 50 off when you
download the doordash app and enter code
b-a-b-e 2023
s-u-m-m-e-r babe 2023 summer don't
forget code babe2023 summer for 50 off
your next order subject to change terms
apply with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hello fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's America's number one meal okay
that's right take a bite out of Summer
with hellofresh from Chef crafted
seasonal recipes to their new fresh and
fit summer menu hello fresh brings
flavor right to the door when you need
dinner fast don't call for delivery baby
think hellofresh they're Fast and Fresh
recipes already in just 15 minutes or
less plus hellofresh is 25 cheaper than
takeout that's right and that's why I
use it all the time especially when I'm
I'm really busy that's when I really
lean into hellofreshing that's when
hellofresh really helps me in my life
specifically amazing now how does
hellofresh save you time how do they do
all that because they make cooking easy
and fast and like we said we love doing
it and we're going to give you guys a
sick discount right now all you got to
do is go to
hellofresh.com
hey babe50 and use the code hey babe50
for 50 off plus free shipping sound just
say it one more time go to
hellofresh.com and uh Slash hey babe
fitty and use code hey baby for 50 uh
off plus free shipping it's it's
basically uh it's hellofreshes America's
number one meal kit boom bap can't get
around it
you have to
put your head on Jazz's Body and Jazz's
head on your body that's all still you
your head is you now you have Jazz's
Body jazz is her she is your body can
you continue the relationship as it is
right now I'm where you now will be
giving Jasmine will be penetrating you
everybody
I guess can you just be like well look
that's me this is her we're still
familiar but you're gonna get like
you're gonna have the female body so
you're saying now everything's the same
except the heads are switched but I am
the one being penetrated I have
Jasmine's body my head she has my body
her head yes on that and your own
Consciousness stay with your head right
I guess it you know first of all I find
I'd feel like what it's you know what
it's like not to
um yeah that
um I think that I think look at this I
think wait wait what just happened this
is now oh that's me and you if yes this
is now if Jasmine's head on my body
dating self sells regular as is body and
head
um
for your hours if
this happens is she going on stage no
you're getting on stage with her body
it's your brain it's my brain I just
have a female body I think that I that
would you be able to keep your
relationship as is and just like the the
you know
hey Will everything can everything else
operate his home will you be able to
think do you think you'd at least as
opposed to Chaz would you be amenable to
being penetrated by your own body
in Jazz's Body
it'd be tough but I think that would be
easier than dealing with her head on
chaz's body yeah of course right right
right
yeah so that's my body it's I got a good
body so do you eat but it's just my head
are you now gonna not have uh sex with
jazz again now because now you don't
need her anymore because you have her
body
that's a good question yeah we don't
want any more kids so that's a good
that's a good question that's a good
um scenario do I just now use my use my
own body to have sex with right right
I'm having sex with my I'll have sex
with myself right
yeah why do I need you to penetrate me
anymore you don't need that but what she
does
she needs to penetrate some someone's
getting penetrated
right so I would do it I would do it out
of an act of love for her I would let
her I would let me I would let her as me
have sex with me but I wouldn't
necessarily need her to just like it's
like probably what it is right now right
she doesn't necessarily need me right
she can do it herself right my role was
there to like you know have kids and
like just you know she can do whatever
she wants with her body it's really The
Men We need the women to like could you
think her brain and your body is going
to want to have sex look at this
[Laughter]
there we go that's exactly what Sir Mix
A Lot was talking about when he said La
faced with an Oakland booty yeah that
that's that's what it is so I you know
it's it's a very interesting thing
um
I don't know
I think uh yeah I think ultimately
I would be able to deal with it the kids
now with the children kind of see what's
happening and be like somebody needs to
speak to us or would their brains be
magically Zapped to say this is just
what we've always expected
what it is this is my dad he's got a
woman's body yeah he's got my mom's body
right right yeah and my mom has my dad's
body right so so it's it's Jasmine is in
the gym lifting weights and everything
like and I'm on the spin box if her
Consciousness feels like she needs that
yeah she probably likes to do no she
probably will keep spinning
and you'll probably keep lifting weights
it's your Consciousness unless you're
gonna say all right my body demands
different things now and you're going to
lean into your female body but if it's
your Consciousness you like lifting
Wings what I will say though what I will
say I don't think this is a gay thing I
would say just to get if there was an
opportunity
like you know how people we've spoken
about how like we can't understand how
people would pay 150 000 or 250 000 to
go to space or go to the bottom of the
ocean we're like why like there's no
reason to
I would though if you told me for 250
Grand
if I had that kind of money I would say
or whatever the money is the money's
arbitrary I would pay top dollar
whatever that meant to me to get the
experience of what it feels like to have
a woman's body for a week I would like
to feel what it is to have a woman I
mean so Freaky Friday I would do that
for a price if there was a way to feel
within everybody
I don't know that it's mind-blowing you
would you would be able to like that is
so who wouldn't be interested what does
it feel like to have ovaries what does a
period feel like what does it feel like
to be penetrated what does it feel like
to have boobs what does it feel like to
you know lotion up my body or like you
know use shampoo and conditioner and
stuff now have you guys what does it
feel like the lotion of my body yeah
have you guys seen the new uh Vince
Vaughn picture from a few years ago
where he freaky Fridays he's playing
yeah yeah any freaky Fridays with a
child yeah really a teen yeah yeah yeah
he's a serial killer that Freaky Friday
so the teen girl becomes serial killer
and he becomes the teacher that's a good
premise oh it's he's really funny in it
too it's really funny
interesting yeah so I would rather pay
for an experience like that than like
going to outer space I would do that in
a second kicking the person though
that's kind of my question are you gonna
pick who
[Music]
like uh in Mario like a random history
about crass
no like meaning like it's a mystery who
you switch with I think it's just a
mystery because then you could I would
do it no matter what because I would be
like you know you would you would pay
top dollar whatever it meant to you to
be a woman for a week oh it depends how
much a disposable income like that that
you said disposable money is not an
object so then take money out of it if I
gave me the option for free I would for
one more week you are a full woman um I
wouldn't even hesitate I wouldn't
hesitate it's insane and it's reversible
yeah right that's what I'm saying
everybody would do it everyone I think
would you
again I need to pick I don't want to pop
up in like a weird part you know well
you're not going to be sent anywhere
okay it's not like you're gonna be
Zapped to the other side you're in the
body no I don't understand the content
you mean Freaky Friday so you mean my
Consciousness is in the female somewhere
yeah not I can what we've been talking
about is my head with a female body so I
could just understand what it is to you
let me put I got another one for you a
little bit harder would you
you're changing cons it is again your
Consciousness and everything your
responsibility so you have to go to work
and do anything but you're a toddler
would you be a toddler for a week just
to experience and remember what it felt
like to be a toddler so I'm asking you
you are you're fully you are way like
big
no like a toddler no like big with Tom
Hanks
I'm a little boy with my brain and I
have to come get on stage at the cellar
he was three years old
that movie must exist no I don't think
it does because they always do like a
tenure I'm talking about you're an
actual toddler to see what a dude if
someone could pull that movie off and
get like a three-year-old or a
four-year-old that can actually carry
the line yeah yeah the funniest thing
I've ever seen in my entire life so
it's interesting though like because I
think about now you know I have a
two-year-old daughter what like what is
it like in being in her butt like what I
don't remember none of us have any
memory what it was like to have to be in
a diaper and what it was like to just be
a you know when I pick up my daughter
and I hold her that's the equivalent of
like you and I just being picked up by
someone who's 15 feet tall and like
you're on a tree that's you so it's like
I wonder if that scares her is it fun
what does she think about sitting in a
car seat like well we'll get this though
your full body then will be occupied by
that three-year-old
what do you mean like or is it just us
going into like no it's my brain and
Consciousness and okay I'm pressing a
button where does this go into your body
yeah that's right no no I'm saying take
them out but they don't exist I'm saying
you can go back to when you were a
three-year-old toddler okay but then I
don't get to so then all I'm
experiencing then is the physical being
of the Toler because you're saying my
life is as per huge I'm going to my job
so what about if you can go back to
being a full toddler at three years old
you don't have any responsibilities
you're in pre-k with my brain no no yeah
of course you basically I inhabit the
body yes
but they don't know that you know but I
do I'm but I'm still leading a
three-year-old's life exactly you want
whatever chicken nuggets you got the
little goldfish sippy cup dude I might
permanently do that you would love to do
that perm dude perm interesting I might
consider perm if it was available
you go back to being three but with
everything I got up here yes but nobody
knows but you uh well I mean now you're
getting into things where it's like all
right do I lose my family do I you know
what I mean but what I'm saying is if
all I had to do was wake up eat and play
yeah
you'll do it I mean and everything about
my life and all the anything that
stresses me is gone but no more drinking
alcohol no more weeds no more but why
because my body can't handle it because
you know because you're being perceived
as a three-year-old so your mom is I
can't even like go in the yard no you
can't do anything right you can't you
don't have you know is this boss baby
you don't have Independence I guess yes
in a way it is you don't have
Independence so I don't so so basically
I have to follow the rules of the House
of my parents your mom and dad are in
charge and I can't say otherwise even
though I can articulate no you can
articulate your bro your brain you you
when you try to say Mom I I so what are
you doing I'm a grown man it comes out
all right so I have it up here yes well
then that feels like weird because then
that's like prison now you're prison but
you're also a toddler and you're gonna
grow up to eventually be you one day
yeah but that or just I'm saying this
right now I'm getting anxiety because it
feels claustrophobic it feels like I
would need to if I couldn't communicate
and this is what kids feel like right
now oh yeah when they try to communicate
but they don't know how yet right I mean
that's you know but I would feel
suffocated if I had my Consciousness but
it just came out
right right that sounds like a coma
thing it's weird Tom a fever dream yeah
but I if I had to go to work
if I had to go to work is it through
like on tour and stuff if I had to go on
tour as a three-year-old yeah and still
have my job yeah that's why if we ever
get to that place in life with something
like would stems cells and swapping and
cloning or whatever and you got young
people older people for me longevity
throwing themselves in young bodies and
that you have like a nine to five
Workforce downtown where half kids walk
around in suits at three years old but
they have an adult Consciousness and
they're someone's boss that's fun I
would watch that movie that's wild
that's wild yeah yeah it's uh it's an
interesting it's about this something
happens boom sci-fi everybody from uh
you know everybody who's old becomes
five and everybody's five becomes like
60. that'd be something and then just
let it play out
that's interesting yeah that's an
interesting thing and and see now
because now you're saying so a
five-year-old
is injected automatically with a
six-year-old's consciousness
yeah and the six-year-old is injected
with a five-year-old's Consciousness
correct wow the sixth year well let's
let's say a 40 year old 40 year old's
home literally in the crib
it's just a huge body right and a bigger
crib just taking you're [__] in the
diaper right
you can't even bathe yourself right but
it's you but it's me yeah and then and
then the toddler yeah is has is a CEO of
a company yes
that's interesting but it happened to
the whole world at once yes everybody
will respect everybody because everybody
happened to everybody yeah
yeah that's the way it's gonna they talk
about that right like taking your
Consciousness and putting on a different
body yeah I think that's going to happen
I think the issue with that would be
like the power dynamics of being a
know-it-all like fourth graders yeah it
depends on what happens by the way I
know there's not a camera on it but we
did not discuss at all and we're almost
at the end of this episode that Homeless
pimp has shorts on and this is the first
time you've ever seen his legs ever in
your life you've never seen homeless
people's blocked by the TV I didn't see
it yeah we have we don't have a wide
right now we do the Y just right here oh
that okay I was looking that down like
wait where's that okay so yeah I was
blocked it's blocked by this but yeah
shorts on I don't think I I know you've
never know I've never seen it stay on
yesterday was the hottest day ever
recorded on earth what or no July 3rd
I'm sorry July 3rd was the hottest day
ever recorded on earth
what you mean like like cumulatively
yes because the average record of all it
got to 62.6 and the previous record was
all because they're taking into a fact
account 130 degrees in Arizona and
negative 30 in Antarctica and the
cumulative average was 62.6 since since
we've even had this record yes 62.4 was
the previous record in August of 2016.
could be caused by recent heat waves in
U.S Canada and Europe uh you think yeah
I mean this is the that's the globe
warming then yes basically wow so that's
why that's why you wore shorts yeah
she's like oh wait so you take the whole
world and averages together and I'm
wearing shorts
the air quality in New York is horrific
again again again and it's about I'm a
guy who checks air quality now I know me
too but they're not they're not the news
it's not talking I wonder where the
media stops because they talking about
this kid about it and they're talking
about how Russia is or or Ukraine is so
close they're gonna blow up a nuclear um
plant
[Music]
Steven Seagal's gonna become defense
minister of Russia is he great he's the
man for the job what he's a man for the
job
he loves uh he is in Russia right now
Seagal right
he's a citizen he he's like Russian is
he yeah we talked about it before he
went full Russian really he went full
Russian wow I had something to say in my
ADHD kicked in or it was a good one too
by the way I just wanted to uh he had a
good point to talk about this this
happened last week but Joey Chestnut
he's won his he won again Hot Dog Eating
competition ate 62 glizzies but you win
ten thousand dollars that's not is that
now that's going to get taxed that money
he probably has a manager or an agent he
has to give 10 percent of that away so
do I mean is that word 62 hot dogs well
I think for him it's just something that
he he doesn't get affected by the
does he this is Healthcare affected or
some of course no like long term but I
think he's doing this a lot of these
Champion eaters actually are in pretty
good shape because they eat they only
eat like that once in a while and they
train their bodies to eat break down
roughage like um the uh Japanese guys
he used to be the champ and Justin who
lost to him a couple times in the
beginning now Chestnut has been
nominated colbyan she doesn't even
participate anymore oh he doesn't I
don't think so 62 is that his own record
I think that's the out record overall
right now 62. 62. and how many 10
minutes yeah this guy in the background
too with that picture he's the best
announcer and it also came out that hot
dogs contain traces of human GNA I saw
that what is that how is that a lot for
a small percentage of human DNA in Hot
Dogs meaning like the people who are
making it if they have fluids or
something get in it they get in it I
don't know I just saw that same article
that said yeah because what can that
mean I don't know he's a cannibal
interesting yeah the way I thought of it
was like human flesh but the thing the
thing to keep in mind is like he goes on
the road for this he goes on tour and
does this in like balls these are his
dates he's chugging like fish in
Baltimore crawfish and right
I think he makes real money though
because he's sponsored by big companies
what happens in the in the bathroom
after this not good what exactly what
happens it's it's bad it's a massacre
well I think I think that they and I
think that they have is he just sitting
on hot dogs whole I think they have to
expel it from their body relatively
quickly I think they have to get it out
I don't think I could just let them have
day jobs too yeah I interviewed a guy
who ranks fourth usually he works at
fresnellis and Soho as a bartender and
he said these guys all work day jobs
this is like uh even Chestnut side
hustle he might be the only one I'll
tell you this I'll tell you I watched it
like last year and they have like like
10 people competing and the women's do
around two and there was ones I don't
remember the guys but there was ones in
the women's I brought this up when I
watched it that like the lead women's
got whatever like 40 right but the last
place person like had like eight I'm not
joking you eight like four
yeah in 10 minutes so that person was
just like yeah I'll do it like they
didn't they literally I was like I could
beat that person yeah yeah yeah they
were like just out of barbecue yeah
that's not embarrassing It's gotta be
the woman's eating 62.
have you how much does a professional
eater make as of June 28 2023 the
average hourly pay for professional
eater in the US is 17.46 an hour which
is Americans I think that's minimum wage
no I think that I think that minimum
wage is lower than that it's like 16 in
La it's 19. okay what is it in New York
I think it's like 16. so it's roughly
this is making what anyone would make
what anyone would make wait so you mean
it's 14 national minimum wage is 15
bones that's too little man that's not
you know we're living in a time where I
do actually think in the next 30 to 40
years the middle class is going to be
completely arrested think about think
about
my kids let's say yeah they are gonna
unless they inherit property or
something from me or my family if we can
hold on to it they are going to be one
of the first Generations where it's not
even a it's not even in the realm of
possibility for the average American
citizen probably World citizen but I'll
say American to own a home in the next
it is not even in the out it is out of
the realm of power you cannot even
strive for it it will all be rentals
it's becoming like like that's how it is
I believe I believe that's how it
already is in China you have the very
very wealthy Elite and then no middle
class and then the poor that's left that
live off the uh government but it feels
like I was thinking about those like how
in the world how is it possible for a a
family average working family with that
with good job say a teacher and a
fireman they can't afford no a
two-bedroom apartment in the cities four
million dollars yeah I don't know
possibly I know so what do we do do what
do we have to do to stop this
well well how can we help here at hey
babe I think instead of getting
political we just say we get a genie
yeah we make a genie wish yeah maybe get
Dr Drew back do we start yeah no it's
insane let's let people live in our
apartment yeah let's let people live in
the studio yeah yeah that's what we're
gonna have to do oh speaking of great
Comics I went to Radio City last week
you know this is slashing right I know
that's bothering you okay I went to
Radio City last weekend I met Ricky
Gervais oh did you go his first of all
his new hour is fantastic I heard it's
fantastic and then I met him before yeah
I went they said it was awesome yes but
oh they were at the Radio City show yeah
oh I was there both nights how random is
that I said it was literally both nights
and you went both nights I went both
nights I'm just love him he's like my
favorite cop if you watch him do the
same hour pretty much yeah and it was
cool to see what you know he felt didn't
work on Friday night adjust and make
better on Saturday night it was dope and
I'll you know we spoke and it was just
it was just so cool and it really it was
it was funny um to just watch him you
know kind of like work it out and he he
reminds you that like you know sitting
in this stands you know sitting in the
crowd sometimes like I think we forget
that like what I felt like is like oh
he's the expert he will tell me whoever
on stage they all tell you the audience
what's funny
but like I I kind of forgot that like I
always was like oh if they're not
laughing it must not be funny but I
forgot that like you know if I think
it's funny then it's funny whether you
laugh or not is irrelevant right right I
want you to laugh but if you don't if
you don't think it's funny that's got
nothing to do with me right I believe
it's funny right right and and you feel
that with Ricky you feel the confidence
and all that where it's like I he
couldn't care less if you're laughing
yeah he's going to continue to do what
you want and of course you do laugh
because it's funny and it's great but I
I was reminded of that that it's like
just you know and it's not a pompous
thing it's not a [__] you thing it's
just like hey like you're I'll tell you
in this show what's going to be funny
and don't worry about Who's Laughing
yeah I think he influenced TV more than
anyone alive no he changed television
yeah he did incredible and you know all
his shows he two Max three seasons he
just any they'll keep green lighting up
he doesn't want it yeah he's like the
last thing I want to do is let it
flutter out yeah I saw him a couple
times I saw him at the the Hulu theater
there whenever it wasn't actually Louis
Louis opened him for him really yeah
this was uh 10 years ago or so Louis was
already a big famous star too yeah he
wasn't as he didn't he wasn't as big as
he was right now but he was big right he
was big but I guess he's still I mean I
mean yeah he was it was definitely like
Ricky's crowd but two times I saw him
Louie open for him yeah and the the guy
you're hoping for him
um Sean McLaughlin is his name and um
and he's awesome he's from England and
um he [__] crushed he's got he's got
a couple like really really really
really really really awesome bits
um and you know it's not easy opening
for somebody like that you got people
sitting down yeah whatever but he got
everybody's focus and crushed so he was
he was cool and I you know met him uh
before the show too and uh yeah it's
just if if Ricky Gervais is coming to
your town go watch the show because and
it's awesome like for him to just kind
of just [__] you know he says he's
one of those comics where it's like what
everybody's thinking the kind of whole
thing in the world he's just like I'm
gonna say it I don't care like it's
almost like he's like a free man and
he's like there's nothing you can take
for me yeah you know I I don't care yeah
he's like the comics version of South
Park almost yeah he's like whatever you
want yeah he's like above it all yeah it
was great and then uh and then yeah and
then and let me start yeah yeah I'm
gonna say Jasmine's body on his
Jasmine's head on Ricky gervas's body
Jasmine's head on Ricky gervais's body
yeah
no I'd rather have Ricky gervais's head
on Jasmine's body because I want Ricky
gervas's Consciousness and I want to be
with Ricky Gervais okay
Don't Be
Afraid don't be ashamed to say hey babe
hey babe
[Music]